my aesthetic for pies is inspired by
color combinations hi i'm lauren co from
loco kitchen and i make geometric and
colorful pies i started the loco kitchen
instagram account on august 29th really
it was just a holding place for my food
photos i was becoming that friend who
was flooding her personal account with
food photos and just really needed a
separate holding place for those photos
before this whole craziness i was an
executive assistant and saw some cool
pie pictures on pinterest and wondered
if i could do it myself so ventured out
and the plaid lattice pie on my feed was
the first one i made my aesthetic for
pies is inspired by geometric patterns
string art architecture a lot of
textiles and color combinations so when
coming up with pie designs i never
sketch things out i don't really plan
them in advance the results of the pie
are usually having fun in the kitchen
and seeing what the dough is willing to
do or the fruit if it cooperates the
feedback to my instagram account and
some of the photos that i've posted have
been really really positive i think one
of my favorite comments was somebody
saying that their partner didn't
understand instagram at all but when
he's in a bad mood or having a bad day
she'll show him some of my photos and it
kind of suits him and calms him down
which i think is pretty funny yeah just
lots of positive comments i love seeing
people out there trying to recreate some
of my designs it's wild that i'm just
having fun in my home kitchen and
somehow these things are getting out in
the world and people are doing the same
thing in their kitchens as well the rule
is always to keep things super cold so
make sure your dough is chilled try not
to handle it too much so my designs are
constructed with lots of strips of dough
so i try to only touch the strips from
the ends once the pie design on top is
set chill it in the fridge thoroughly
before baking for the loco kitchen
signature spoke design that's inspired
by some string art designs that i saw
and because the design is constructed of
lines i wondered if i could reconstruct
it with pie dough just cutting the dough
into strips and laying them on the
surface of the pies set out to
experiment per usual and it turned out
well one of the first pies i made i
brought to thanksgiving at my in-laws
house and i had made this beautiful
intricate top was super proud of it it
looked awesome and lo and behold it was
completely undercooked and runny and it
was just mortifying sitting at the table
it was the one dessert and
everybody in the family was just really
kind and generous and insisted on eating
it and i had to sit there totally
mortified and embarrassed you know i
kept baking and through experimenting
and practice i've gotten a little bit
better i had this idea of making colored
pie dough and it was just kind of
floating around in my head and i tried
it out with freeze-dried raspberry
powder it colored the dough a really
kind of scary color still put it up
joked about it and a chef actually
commented on that photo and suggested
using beet compound butter she actually
emailed me and kind of walked me through
the steps of constructing this beet
compound butter and substituting beet
juice for the water in the dough recipe
and yeah it worked out really well the
dough color came out very vibrant there
are a couple people on instagram that
i've met through the platform now that
i'm deep into pies one of them is joe
harrington she's based in london i think
she's one of the original instagram pie
ladies and she makes these really
beautiful pies out of floral and leaf
cutouts just by the magic of the
internet we've kind of become friends
and she's been super kind super generous
with her platform was always advocating
for me and just kind of cheering me on
which i find really inspiring that the
community can be so collaborative and
encouraging yeah it's just another
testament to how this instagram platform
has reached people all over the world
and how people have been really kind and
responded really positively in sharing
their own knowledge with me as well my
husband his role is usually not super
hands-on occasionally if i do attempt a
weaving pattern or some kind of pie
dough pattern and i get stuck i'll have
to call in my life consultant and have
them kind of figure out the pattern and
tell me what my next steps are otherwise
he kind of keeps out of the kitchen lets
me do my thing
usually i prefer making tarts because i
also prefer to eat them for the tangy
zesty flavor but i think they're a
little less time intensive and there's a
lot more creative freedom with hearts
so i think my family and friends are all
really excited to see what's happening
with my instagram account and the way
that it's completely exploded
i did have to explain how the instagram
platform worked to my parents and a lot
of family and i will say a lot of people
have gotten new instagram accounts just
so they can follow me had to walk them
through the process of how to like a
photo how to leave a comment but for the
most part i think they're all super
excited to see the things that i'm
creating being shared all over the world
so when i'm cutting out shapes for tarts
or you know cutting out cubes of fruit
for pie fillings there's a lot of
leftovers some edges some bits i usually
stick those in a freezer
ziploc bag and save those for smoothies
later
for extra pie dough anything that i trim
or any extra leftover pie strips and i
usually sprinkle those with either
cinnamon sugar or parmesan cheese and
bake them up and they become pie fries
so i don't usually work with fresh
things like apples and pears for tarts
because they do brown really quickly i
keep those ingredients for pie fillings
instead
what i find easiest is working with
fruit that's not overly ripe fruits that
are more solid i guess like greener
mangoes firmer kiwis dragon fruit things
like that are easier to work with and
you're able to get sharper edges out of
those cuts
i think it's something that's really
intimidating but anybody can do it i
started with a sharp knife and a cookie
sheet for cutting straight edges and you
know i don't have a lot of fancy tools
that i use or any fancy recipes let's
just get in the kitchen do it and see
what comes out and have fun
oh yes
you